This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For every disease, illness, or discomfort, there is a drug. There are so many drugs. Drugs that seemingly work miracles and change the world, and drugs that are put in the service of fighting a malady for decades, only to learn much too late that they have almost no effect at all. You could tell the story of the world through the drugs we take and the diseases they are designed to manage.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。每一种疾病、病痛或不适，都有对应的药物。药物种类繁多。有些药物看似创造了奇迹，改变了世界；而有些药物在与某种疾病抗争了几十年后，人们才迟迟发现它们几乎毫无作用。你可以通过我们服用的药物以及它们旨在治疗的疾病，来讲述这个世界的故事。
This is what the new podcast, Drug Story, is all about. On the show, creator and host Thomas Getz tells the story of the disease business, one drug at a time. Each episode explores one disease and one drug. Drugs end up being an incredible lens to view our world. This week, we are featuring an episode of Drug Story, an independent documentary journalism podcast, the kind of podcast you just don't hear about anymore and one that deserves your full attention. It is so good. I've listened to every episode.
这就是新播客《药物故事》（Drug Story）的主题。在节目中，创作者兼主持人托马斯·盖茨（Thomas Getz）以一种药物为切入点，讲述了疾病产业的故事。每一集探讨一种疾病和一种药物。药物最终成为了观察我们世界的绝佳视角。本周，我们将播出《药物故事》中的一集，这是一个独立的纪录片式新闻播客，这种播客你现在已经很少听到了，而且它值得你全神贯注地聆听。它非常棒。我已经听完了每一集。
Here's one of my favorites. Imagine living with constant itching that never stops. Or slowly losing your sight, not because of age, but because of a simple fly bite. That is the reality of oncocychosis, also known as river blindness. One small tablet of ibermectin, taking once or twice a year, helps stop transmission and protects entire communities. This is how itching stops. This is how blindness is prevented.
这是我最喜欢的一集。想象一下，生活在永无止境的持续瘙痒中。或者慢慢失去视力，不是因为年龄，而仅仅是因为被苍蝇叮了一口。这就是盘尾丝虫病（oncocychosis）的现实，也被称为河盲症。每年服用一两次一片小小的伊维菌素（ibermectin），有助于阻断传播并保护整个社区。这就是瘙痒如何停止，这就是失明如何被预防。
And this is how a generation grows up free from river blindness. Imagine that you are a worm. A very specific kind of worm, uncocerca volvulus. Your goal in life, your mission, your only purpose is to worm your way into the human body. You are a parasite. You need the human body to survive and to thrive. Humans, perhaps understandably, do not care for you.
这就是一代人如何成长并免受河盲症困扰。想象一下你是一条蠕虫。一种非常特殊的蠕虫，旋盘尾丝虫（oncocerca volvulus）。你的人生目标、你的使命、你唯一的目的就是钻进人体。你是一种寄生虫。你需要人体来生存和繁衍。人类，或许可以理解，并不喜欢你。
They curse you and your larvae, your larvae especially, because once they get into humans, they squirm everywhere. They crawl into legs, and they cause unbelievable itching, horrible, infernal itching. And when they writhe into the eyes, humans go blind. For centuries, there was nothing humans could do but spite you. But then they found a pill, a horrible pill that kills your darlings. This pill, Ivermectin, makes life very difficult for a parasite. Welcome to Drug Story. I'm Thomas Gatz.
他们诅咒你和你的幼虫，尤其是你的幼虫，因为一旦它们进入人体，就会到处蠕动。它们爬进腿部，引起难以置信的瘙痒，那种可怕的、地狱般的瘙痒。当它们钻进眼睛时，人类就会失明。几个世纪以来，人类除了憎恨你别无他法。但后来他们发现了一种药丸，一种能杀死你心爱之物的可怕药丸。这种药丸——伊维菌素，让寄生虫的生活变得非常艰难。欢迎来到《药物故事》。我是托马斯·盖茨。
Today's drug is Ivermectin, which truly is a wonder drug, a veritable miracle cure. It is really, really good at killing parasites that causes. diseases like river blindness or elephant tiasis. These tropical diseases mostly happen in Africa or South America or parts of Asia. Ivermectin is also effective against hookworm, which a century ago was endemic in the southern United States. And it's good on heartworm which affects pets, dogs and cats, and it kills parasites in horses or other livestock. But in the United States, these days, you have probably heard of ivermectin not as a treatment for river blindness, but for different purposes altogether.
今天的药物是伊维菌素，它确实是一种神奇的药物，一种名副其实的奇迹疗法。它在杀死导致河盲症或象皮病等疾病的寄生虫方面非常非常有效。这些热带疾病大多发生在非洲、南美洲或亚洲的部分地区。伊维菌素对钩虫也有效，一个世纪前，钩虫在美国南部曾是地方性流行病。它对影响宠物（猫狗）的心丝虫也有效，还能杀死马匹或其他牲畜体内的寄生虫。但在今天的美国，你可能听说过伊维菌素，但不是作为治疗河盲症的药物，而是出于完全不同的目的。
I just did a parasite cleanse. I never thought those words would come out of me. Things literally came out of me. I've used ivermectin when I was really sick. Yeah, and honestly, I actually think, you know, I've seen a lot of studies. I think that it's probably not a bad idea to use it once or twice a year to cleanse it out of your body, right? Right. Some of my patients will take ivermectin as a prevention for viral illnesses.
我刚做了一次寄生虫清理。我从没想过这些话会从我嘴里说出来。东西确实从我体内排出来了。我生重病时用过伊维菌素。是的，老实说，我真的认为，你知道，我看过很多研究。我认为每年使用一两次来清理体内寄生虫可能不是个坏主意，对吧？没错。我的一些病人会服用伊维菌素来预防病毒性疾病。
Totally fine, totally safe. I use ivermectin for 12 by 12, 7 days, which is every 12 hours, 12 milligrams, for 7 days. And the reason is all the literature that's coming out about ivermectin is an antichancer. You know if you have a hidden parasite and how do you get rid of it. I recommend doing a parasitic detox, which you should talk to your own doctor about because I am not licensed to practice medicine, but I do take a form of ivermectin and van Bendazole. So, yeah, Google tells me that right now. there are many tens of thousands of videos on YouTube raving about ivermectin.
完全没问题，非常安全。我使用伊维菌素的方法是“12乘12”，持续7天，也就是每12小时服用12毫克，连服7天。原因在于所有关于伊维菌素作为抗癌药物的文献都在涌现。你知道，如果你有隐性寄生虫，该如何摆脱它呢？我建议进行一次寄生虫排毒，你应该和自己的医生谈谈，因为我没有行医执照，但我确实服用某种形式的伊维菌素和苯并咪唑（van Bendazole）。所以，是的，谷歌告诉我，现在YouTube上有成千上万个视频在狂热地吹捧伊维菌素。
But cancer, parasite cleanses, and viruses? What is this drug? What does ivermectin do, really? In this episode of drug story, we're going to tell the story of ivermectin, this amazing medicine. We are going to talk about parasites a lot. And we will dig into what got all those people on YouTube and Instagram talking about ivermectin. But they have... hope it could be what they believe it works on. Not just parasitic diseases, but viral diseases
但是癌症、寄生虫清理和病毒？这到底是什么药？伊维菌素到底有什么作用？在这一集《药物故事》中，我们将讲述伊维菌素这种神奇药物的故事。我们将大量讨论寄生虫。我们还将深入探讨是什么让YouTube和Instagram上的那些人开始谈论伊维菌素。但他们有……希望它能成为他们所相信的那种有效药物。不仅是针对寄生虫病，还有病毒性疾病。
like COVID or even cancer, which would be great if there's, you know, evidence that it actually works for those other diseases. So we're going to explore that today with an open mind, an open notebook, and an open door to science in the drug story ahead. We tell each episode in three parts, diagnosis, the prescription, and side effects. This is part one, the diagnosis, where we explore the disease behind the drug. Or in this case, the disease is, because ivermectin is proven to work on many diseases, diseases with one thing in common. They are caused not by it bacteria or a virus, but by an animal, a parasite. Oftentimes, it's a type of worm called a helmuth. Now, technically speaking, a parasite is an organism that lives inside or on another creature and feeds off of it.
比如新冠肺炎，甚至是癌症。如果真的有证据表明它对这些其他疾病有效，那将是非常棒的。所以今天我们将以开放的心态、开放的笔记本和对科学开放的态度来探索这一点。在接下来的《药物故事》中，我们分三个部分讲述每一集：诊断、处方和副作用。这是第一部分：诊断，我们将探索药物背后的疾病。或者在这种情况下，是多种疾病，因为伊维菌素已被证明对许多疾病有效，这些疾病有一个共同点。它们不是由细菌或病毒引起的，而是由一种动物——寄生虫引起的。通常，这是一种被称为蠕虫（helmuth）的寄生虫。从技术上讲，寄生虫是一种生活在另一种生物体内或体表并以其为食的生物。
A tick is a parasite, so our lice, as is the tongue-eating louse. That's this little crustacean, it's a relative of a shrimp that swims into a fish's gills, winds its way into the mouth, and then eats the fish's tongue. Yeah. And get this, it then takes the place of that tongue. It lives there in the mouth, helping the fish eat, just as a tongue would, but taking a nibble of food every now and again. That, my friends, is a parasite. There are thousands, maybe millions of parasites on Earth. It just makes your skin crawl.
蜱虫是寄生虫，虱子也是，还有食舌虱。那是一种小甲壳动物，是虾的近亲，它游进鱼的鳃里，钻进嘴里，然后吃掉鱼的舌头。是的。而且最绝的是，它随后会取代那条舌头的位置。它住在嘴里，像舌头一样帮助鱼进食，但偶尔会咬上一口食物。我的朋友们，那就是寄生虫。地球上有成千上万，甚至数百万种寄生虫。这简直让人毛骨悚然。
In fact, there's actually a condition called delusional infestation, also called delusional parasitosis, where people are convinced that they have parasites. You might feel a bit of this right now. feeling like something is crawling on your skin, under your socks, maybe under your shirt. It's a little itchy. And no, a parasitic cleanse is not the answer. There is no evidence that those cleanses work.
事实上，有一种叫做“妄想性寄生虫病”（delusional infestation），也叫“妄想性寄生虫病”（delusional parasitosis），患者坚信自己身上有寄生虫。你现在可能也会有这种感觉。感觉有什么东西在你的皮肤上、袜子下，或者衬衫下爬行。有点痒。不，寄生虫清理并不是答案。没有任何证据表明这些清理方法有效。
If you really think you have parasites, go see a doctor. Do not DIY this. Anyway, parasites have been warming their way into the human body for as long as there have been humans, even before. Just as fish and birds and dogs and horses all get parasitic infections, so do we. Many of these parasitic diseases started in the trunks. Since about 1492, basically over the past 600 years of conquest and migration and slavery, parasitic diseases have spread around the world. Parasites are everywhere.
如果你真的认为自己有寄生虫，去看医生。不要自己动手。总之，只要有人类存在，甚至在人类出现之前，寄生虫就一直在往人体里钻。就像鱼、鸟、狗和马都会感染寄生虫一样，我们也会。许多这些寄生虫病起源于热带地区。自1492年左右，基本上在过去600年的征服、移民和奴隶制过程中，寄生虫病传播到了世界各地。寄生虫无处不在。
Here's a factoid. The U.S. Centers for Disease Control and Prevention is based in Atlanta, Georgia, because 75 years ago, parasitic diseases were common in the deep south. It was mostly malaria, but also hookworm. In fact, let's start our tale there in the southern United States with a story about hookworms, circa 1900. Charles Stiles was born in New York and educated in the zoological sciences at the finest institutions in Europe.
这里有一个小知识。美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）总部设在佐治亚州亚特兰大，因为75年前，寄生虫病在美国南部深处非常普遍。主要是疟疾，但也包括钩虫。事实上，让我们从美国南部开始我们的故事，讲讲1900年左右的钩虫。查尔斯·斯泰尔斯（Charles Stiles）出生于纽约，在欧洲最顶尖的机构接受过动物学教育。
Stiles was particularly interested in parasites and livestock, like trichinosis in swine and tapeworm in cattle. At the time, the study of parasites, this is called parasitology, this was a brand new field of medicine. Parasites, it was discovered, caused diseases like jaradia and malaria, and compared to bacteria, parasites were easier to find, sometimes even visible to the naked eye without a microscope. But that did not make them any easier to deal with. So, around 1900, Charles Stiles took a job as the chief zoologist for the U.S. Public Health Service. and when he heard about health problems in the American South,
斯泰尔斯对牲畜寄生虫特别感兴趣，比如猪的旋毛虫病和牛的绦虫。当时，寄生虫的研究，即寄生虫学，是一门全新的医学领域。人们发现，寄生虫会导致贾第鞭毛虫病和疟疾等疾病，而且与细菌相比，寄生虫更容易被发现，有时甚至无需显微镜，肉眼就能看到。但这并没有让它们变得更容易对付。因此，1900年左右，查尔斯·斯泰尔斯担任了美国公共卫生局的首席动物学家。当他听说美国南部的健康问题时，
anemia, stunted growth, he had a hunch that parasites were involved. So Stiles began to research, well, there's really no other way to say this, he went on a study of human shit across the South. He took stool samples from everyone willing to let him, and soon he had definitively identified hookworms as a cause of widespread malaise.
贫血、发育迟缓，他直觉认为这与寄生虫有关。于是斯泰尔斯开始研究——好吧，真的没有别的说法了——他在美国南部进行了一项关于人类粪便的研究。他从所有愿意配合的人那里采集了粪便样本，很快他就明确地确定了钩虫是导致广泛不适的原因。
Based on his poop studies, he estimated that around 40% of Southerners, whites and blacks, almost always poor, they carried hookworms. He called these parasites necator Americanaus, which translates as American murderer. This was a misnomer, actually. People rarely die of hookworm infections. But hookworms did make daily life much, much worse. At the time, this was the first years of the 20th century, To be poor in the South meant almost no sanitation. No running water, no toilets, often no outhouses. People pooped, well, wherever, in the woods, behind bushes.
根据他的粪便研究，他估计大约40%的南方人（白人和黑人，几乎都是穷人）携带钩虫。他将这些寄生虫命名为“美洲板口线虫”（necator Americanaus），翻译过来就是“美国杀手”。这其实是个误称。人们很少死于钩虫感染。但钩虫确实让日常生活变得非常非常糟糕。当时，也就是20世纪初的头几年，在南方贫穷意味着几乎没有卫生设施。没有自来水，没有厕所，通常连茅房都没有。人们随地排便，在树林里，在灌木丛后面。
And most poor people went without shoes, children especially. It was just easier that way. Shoes cost money. These were ideal conditions for the hookworm to prosper. Let's start in the dirt. Hookworm larvae live in the soil and burrow through to reach their target, human feet, where they quickly slip into the pores of bare skin.
而且大多数穷人都不穿鞋，尤其是孩子。那样更方便。鞋子要花钱。这些都是钩虫繁衍的理想条件。让我们从泥土开始。钩虫幼虫生活在土壤中，钻入人体皮肤以到达目标——人类的脚，然后迅速滑入裸露皮肤的毛孔中。
This might cause a rash, it was called groundage. But the worm is in. The larvae, which are super tiny, scarcely visible to the human eye, they then wriggle their way into blood vessels and enter the bloodstream. And now the ride is on. The larvae flow to the heart, and they are pumped out into the lungs. This usually causes a cough. which is just what the hookworm needs.
这可能会引起皮疹，被称为“地面瘙痒”（groundage）。但虫子已经进去了。幼虫非常微小，肉眼几乎看不见，它们随后蠕动进血管并进入血液循环。现在旅程开始了。幼虫流向心脏，被泵入肺部。这通常会导致咳嗽，而这正是钩虫所需要的。
Because with every cough, the hookworm is forced out of the lungs into the mouth, and then gulp, swallowed. And now the worm is home-free. In the small intestine, the worm latches onto the intestinal wall. There it feeds on blood and grows to just half an inch long at most. From there, the adult worm produces more larvae, which are expelled with a stool into the dirt past the bush. where the worms wait for other feet to pass by.
因为每一次咳嗽，钩虫都会被迫从肺部进入口腔，然后被吞下。现在虫子就安全了。在小肠里，虫子附着在肠壁上。在那里，它以血液为食，长到最多半英寸长。从那里，成虫产生更多的幼虫，随粪便排出到灌木丛后的泥土中，等待其他人的脚经过。
And so the cycle continues. But let's hook back, sorry, to the adult worms, back in the intestines. As they fester, sucking the blood out of their host, hookworms cause anemia. That is, a severe and chronic iron deficiency caused by blood loss. Symptoms of anemia are weakness and extreme fatigue. The English language is full of words to describe this. indolence, sloth, lethargy, lassitude, laziness.
循环就这样继续下去。但让我们回到肠道里的成虫。当它们在宿主体内作祟，吸食宿主的血液时，钩虫会导致贫血。也就是说，由失血引起的严重且慢性的缺铁。贫血的症状是虚弱和极度疲劳。英语中有很多词来描述这种状态：懒散、怠惰、嗜睡、倦怠、懒惰。
In 1902, at the Pan-American Sanitary Congress in Washington, D.C., Charles Stiles announced his discovery, and he noted that there might be a connection between this hookworm, the American killer, and the characteristic state of southern lassitude. And that became front-page news. The headline in the New York Sun screamed, germ of laziness found. At the time, this stereotype of a lazy southerner, especially white southerners, it was commonplace.
1902年，在华盛顿特区举行的泛美卫生大会上，查尔斯·斯泰尔斯宣布了他的发现，并指出这种“美国杀手”钩虫与南方人特有的懒散状态之间可能存在联系。这成了头条新闻。《纽约太阳报》的标题惊呼：“懒惰的病菌被发现”。当时，这种南方人（尤其是南方白人）懒惰的刻板印象非常普遍。
As the north expanded in a frenzy of industrialization, the South was still overwhelmingly rural. Poor white southerners were scorned as unmotivated and slow, and the stereotype lined up neatly with racial slurs about lazy black people. And that has been an even more enduring, So Charles Stiles had found his cause. But what about the cure? Once the germ for laziness headlines faded, no one seemed that interested in following up on Stiles' work
随着北方在工业化狂潮中扩张，南方仍然以农村为主。贫穷的南方白人被嘲笑为缺乏动力和迟钝，这种刻板印象与关于黑人懒惰的种族歧视言论不谋而合。这甚至成了一种更持久的偏见。所以查尔斯·斯泰尔斯找到了他的事业。但治疗方法呢？当“懒惰病菌”的头条新闻热度消退后，似乎没有人对跟进斯泰尔斯的研究感兴趣，
to do anything about the hookworms. It may have affected 40% of the population, sure, but hookworm was mostly an affliction of the very poor, and often blacks. Remember, this was the Jim Crow era South, not a time of great progress. progress. So this was just not a priority for the fledgling U.S. Public Health Service or the growing nation. So Stiles started stumping and lecturing about what he thought should be done. He said, my hobby may be summarized in the two words, clean up. In our filthy American habits
也没有人想对钩虫采取任何行动。它可能影响了40%的人口，没错，但钩虫主要是极度贫困人口（通常是黑人）的苦难。记住，那是吉姆·克劳法时代的南方，不是一个进步的时代。所以这根本不是刚起步的美国公共卫生局或这个成长中的国家的优先事项。于是斯泰尔斯开始四处演讲，谈论他认为应该做的事情。他说：“我的爱好可以用两个词来概括：清理。在我们肮脏的美国日常生活习惯中，
of daily life, I see the cause of more preventable sickness and preventable death than I do in any other one factor. Eventually, in 1908, Stiles hooked up, sorry, with advisors to John D. Rockefeller, the founder of the Standard Oil Company and the richest person in the United States at the time. Rockefeller was interested in putting his wealth towards philanthropy, and Stiles' work fit the bill. Soon there was a Rockefeller Sanitary Commission dedicated to eradicating hookworm in the Southern United States. This would later become the Rockefeller Foundation. Stiles and the Rockefeller team identified three strategies to fight hookworm. First, infected people were to be treated with thymol.
我看到了比任何其他因素都多的可预防疾病和可预防死亡的原因。”最终，在1908年，斯泰尔斯与约翰·D·洛克菲勒（标准石油公司创始人，当时美国最富有的人）的顾问们取得了联系。洛克菲勒有兴趣将他的财富用于慈善事业，而斯泰尔斯的工作正好符合要求。不久，就成立了洛克菲勒卫生委员会，致力于根除美国南部的钩虫。这后来成为了洛克菲勒基金会。斯泰尔斯和洛克菲勒团队确定了三种对抗钩虫的策略。首先，感染者要用百里酚进行治疗。
This was a naturally occurring chemical used as a disinfectant, and Epsom salt to kill and purge the worms. This involved a lot of vomiting and diarrhea, but it usually worked to rid a body of worms within 24 hours. Second, they went on an outhouse building campaign. One estimate at the time held that 35% of white households, and 75% of black households had no privies. That would have to change.
这是一种天然存在的化学物质，用作消毒剂，并用泻盐来杀死和排出蠕虫。这涉及大量的呕吐和腹泻，但通常能在24小时内清除体内的蠕虫。其次，他们开展了一场建造茅房的运动。当时的一项估计显示，35%的白人家庭和75%的黑人家庭没有厕所。这种情况必须改变。
The goal was to build an outhouse for every home with a pit at least four feet deep. Third, shoes. Now, this was a big cultural change. Children in the South rarely wore shoes, especially in the summer. But shoes keep the worms out. The hookworm campaign quickly took off. State governments got engaged. With Rockefeller money, many southern states established sanitary commissions
目标是为每个家庭建造一个坑深至少四英尺的茅房。第三，鞋子。这是一种巨大的文化变革。南方的孩子很少穿鞋，尤其是在夏天。但鞋子能把虫子挡在外面。钩虫运动迅速开展起来。州政府也参与了进来。有了洛克菲勒的资金，许多南方州建立了卫生委员会，
and better state departments of health. Soon, there was talk of an expanded national public health service, one that could build on the success of the hookworm campaign and advance sanitation and health care across the land. The Rockefeller Coalition framed this as a movement for the conservation of country life. But they were really demanding that people change how they lived, where they lived, what they wore, how they ate.
并改善了州卫生部门。不久，人们开始谈论建立一个扩大的国家公共卫生服务机构，一个能够建立在钩虫运动成功基础之上，并在全国范围内推进卫生和医疗保健的机构。洛克菲勒联盟将其定义为一场“乡村生活保护运动”。但他们实际上是在要求人们改变生活方式、居住地、穿着和饮食习惯。
Change was the only way to keep disease at bay. And many people did not like all that change. Enter the National League of Medical Freedom. This opposition group condemned scientific medicine, arguing that people should be free to pursue whatever form of treatment they believed best, and that the federal government should steer clear of endorsing certain kinds of medicine as more worthy than others.
改变是抵御疾病的唯一途径。许多人不喜欢这种改变。于是“全国医疗自由联盟”登场了。这个反对组织谴责科学医学，认为人们应该有权自由选择他们认为最好的任何治疗方式，联邦政府应该避免支持某些类型的医学而贬低其他类型。
The League was funded by homeopaths, osteopaths, and others in the alternative medicine business. At first, it worked. The League and a successor group, the American Medical Liberty League, they managed to delay approval of what was called the Medical Octopus, a stronger national health organization. But by the time of the New Deal and more effective drugs and treatments in the 1930s, the opposition faded, though it did not disappear. That idea of defending medical freedoms against mainstream medicine,
该联盟由顺势疗法医生、整骨疗法医生和替代医学行业的其他人资助。起初，它奏效了。该联盟及其后续组织“美国医疗自由联盟”成功推迟了被称为“医疗章鱼”的更强大的国家卫生组织的批准。但到了新政时期，随着1930年代更有效的药物和治疗方法的出现，反对声浪减弱了，尽管并没有完全消失。那种捍卫医疗自由以对抗主流医学的理念，
does that sound familiar? That idea would not die. It has not died. So now back to Hookworm. That was eliminated in the southern U.S. more or less by the 1950s, though it's not entirely gone from the South. And it still appears in dogs and cats and horses nationwide. And Hookworm is still sadly common around the world.
听起来耳熟吗？那种理念不会消亡。它至今未亡。现在回到钩虫。到1950年代，它在美国南部基本上被消除了，尽管在南方并没有完全绝迹。而且它在全国各地的猫狗和马匹身上仍然出现。不幸的是，钩虫在世界各地仍然很常见。
which takes us to another worm. Let's follow our drug story to Africa to meet another parasitic disease, river blindness. In the villages of sub-Saharan Africa, in countries like Ghana, Nigeria, and Cameroon, people depend on rivers, because that is where the food is, where the water is, that's where the work is.
这把我们带到了另一种蠕虫。让我们跟随我们的药物故事来到非洲，去了解另一种寄生虫病——河盲症。在撒哈拉以南非洲的村庄里，在加纳、尼日利亚和喀麦隆等国家，人们依赖河流，因为那里有食物，有水，有工作。
The water from the rivers is precious indeed, but the rivers are treacherous. They produce the black fly that brings blindness. That's from a 1983 documentary about river blindness. The black flies bite, and with a bite, they transmit the larvae of a worm called Ancocerca volvilus.
河水确实珍贵，但河流也充满危险。它们滋生了带来失明的黑蝇。这是1983年一部关于河盲症的纪录片中的内容。黑蝇叮咬，叮咬的同时，它们传播一种叫做“旋盘尾丝虫”的蠕虫幼虫。
The worm grows and breeds under the skin. The human body generally tolerates the adult worms with a low immune response. But when the baby worms, the larvae get into the eye, a more intense immune reaction can cause inflammation, and that leads to blindness. River blindness itself is rarely deadly to individuals, but it can prove fatal to a family or to a village,
蠕虫在皮肤下生长和繁殖。人体通常能耐受成虫，免疫反应较低。但当幼虫进入眼睛时，更强烈的免疫反应会导致炎症，从而导致失明。河盲症本身很少对个人致命，但对一个家庭或村庄来说可能是毁灭性的，
because blindness often comes to men and women in their prime productive years. Sons or daughters must drop out of the workforce to care for a blind parent. Marriages and parenthood are less common. Eventually, young people flee the village. For decades, there was little to be done for oncocercysis. As many as 20 million people were infected with the parasite worldwide, and hundreds of thousands were blinded or had impaired vision because of the disease. In the 1970s, the World Bank began using DDT and other insecticides
因为失明往往发生在男女处于生产力最旺盛的时期。儿子或女儿必须辍学去照顾失明的父母。婚姻和生育变得不那么常见。最终，年轻人逃离了村庄。几十年来，对于盘尾丝虫病几乎无计可施。全世界有多达2000万人感染了这种寄生虫，数十万人因该病失明或视力受损。1970年代，世界银行开始使用滴滴涕（DDT）和其他杀虫剂，
to kill black fly populations in West Africa. This worked in places, but it was terrifically dangerous to the environment and to human health. And then in 1981, a new drug appeared that might work for river blindness, and for other parasitic diseases too, including hookworm. This was Ivermectin, and we'll get into that after a break in part two. Welcome back to Drug Story. This is part two, the prescription, where we explore the creation and the use of a drug to treat disease. and today's drug is, of course, Ivermectin. The creation of Ivermectin begins, of all places on a golf course,
来消灭西非的黑蝇种群。这在某些地方奏效了，但对环境和人类健康极其危险。然后，在1981年，一种可能对河盲症以及包括钩虫在内的其他寄生虫病有效的新药出现了。这就是伊维菌素，我们将在第二部分休息后详细介绍。欢迎回到《药物故事》。这是第二部分：处方，我们将探索一种用于治疗疾病的药物的研发和使用。今天的药物当然是伊维菌素。伊维菌素的研发始于一个意想不到的地方——高尔夫球场，
south of Tokyo, Japan in 1973. On the edge of the course, looking east over Sagami Bay, a young scientist named Satoshi Omura was digging up dirt. Now, at the time, it was well known that soil, dirt, was full of life and full of microbes. In any patch of earth, a war is going on. with various bacteria producing chemical agents to kill off rival bacteria in the quest for food and survival. Since 1943, it was known that some of those microbes could be isolated and turned into medicines.
1973年，日本东京南部。在球场边缘，向东俯瞰相模湾，一位名叫大村智（Satoshi Omura）的年轻科学家正在挖掘泥土。当时，人们已经知道土壤里充满了生命和微生物。在任何一块土地上，一场战争都在进行，各种细菌产生化学制剂来杀死竞争对手，以争夺食物和生存空间。自1943年以来，人们就知道其中一些微生物可以被分离出来并制成药物。
One of the first antibiotics, Streptomycin, was isolated out of soil. Tetracycline, rapamycin, and a dozen other medicines started in dirt. O'Mora was a director at the Kitasato Institute, and he had just begun a research project with Merck, the New Jersey-based pharma company. Part of Amura's habit was to carry sample bags with him, so that when the mood struck him, he could shovel up a soil sample for testing later. The sample from that golf course was just one of 40,000 cultures isolated in Amura's lab. The promising ones were then sent overseas to New Jersey,
最早的抗生素之一——链霉素，就是从土壤中分离出来的。四环素、雷帕霉素和其他十几种药物都始于泥土。大村智是北里研究所的所长，他刚刚与总部位于新泽西州的制药公司默克（Merck）开始了一个研究项目。大村智的一个习惯是随身携带样品袋，这样当他有灵感时，就可以铲起一份土壤样本供以后测试。那个高尔夫球场的样本只是大村实验室分离出的4万个培养物中的一个。有希望的样本随后被送往海外的新泽西州，
and exactly one turned out to have an anti-parasic. effect. It killed worms. For the next few years, the Merck team, led by William Campbell, they sweated this stuff, trying to create a stronger brew of this microbe. They tested it against various pathogens from bacteria to parasites. And after countless experiments, they had Ivermectin, a drug that worked reliably and consistently to kill parasites in livestock. In 1981, Ivermectin was approved for use in animals to kill various kinds of parasites, mites and ticks and roundworms and hookworms and heartworms. Merck would make a lot of money this way.
结果只有一个表现出了抗寄生虫作用。它能杀死蠕虫。在接下来的几年里，由威廉·坎贝尔（William Campbell）领导的默克团队对这种物质进行了深入研究，试图制造出更强效的微生物制剂。他们针对从细菌到寄生虫的各种病原体进行了测试。经过无数次实验，他们得到了伊维菌素，一种能可靠且持续地杀死牲畜体内寄生虫的药物。1981年，伊维菌素被批准用于动物，以杀死各种寄生虫、螨虫、蜱虫、圆虫、钩虫和心丝虫。默克公司通过这种方式赚了很多钱。
But parasites were also a problem in humans, particularly in less developed countries. So that same year, in Senegal, Merckin began testing Ivermectin in people for the prevention and treatment of river blindness. And those experiments worked too. Ivermectin was approved for use in humans in 1987. But who would pay for the drug? It would be no small expense to manufacture and distribute the drug to hundreds of millions of people worldwide.
但寄生虫在人类中也是一个问题，特别是在欠发达国家。因此，同年，在塞内加尔，默克公司开始在人体上测试伊维菌素，用于预防和治疗河盲症。这些实验也成功了。伊维菌素于1987年被批准用于人类。但谁来支付药费呢？在全球范围内生产并向数亿人分发这种药物，绝非易事。
So Merck did something remarkable. The company agreed to give away the drug for free, as much as needed and as long as needed, as the company's chairman said at the time. Within a few years, Ivermectin was being distributed to whole villages, whole countries. Soon, people started returning to the rivers in a land rush as villages and communities were reborn with hope. And then another triumph. In the mid-1990s, Ivermectin
于是默克做了一件了不起的事。正如公司董事长当时所说，公司同意免费提供这种药物，需要多少就提供多少，需要多久就提供多久。几年之内，伊维菌素就开始分发到整个村庄、整个国家。很快，人们开始回到河流边，随着村庄和社区重获希望，土地开发热潮也随之而来。然后是另一个胜利。1990年代中期，伊维菌素
was proven effective for treating lymphatic filariasis. Another widespread parasitic disease. In this case, worms delivered by a mosquito bite. This disease afflicts 100 million people and causes chronic swelling in the limbs and genitals, leading to horrible conditions like elephant tiasis. Again, Merck donated the drug for free. Forty years after these triumphs, we now know that ivermectin works against a great many parasites, and it is easy to take just one or two pills a year.
被证明对治疗淋巴丝虫病有效。这是另一种广泛传播的寄生虫病。在这种情况下，蠕虫通过蚊子叮咬传播。这种疾病困扰着1亿人，导致四肢和生殖器慢性肿胀，引发象皮病等可怕的状况。同样，默克公司免费捐赠了这种药物。在这些胜利40年后，我们现在知道伊维菌素对许多寄生虫有效，而且每年只需服用一两片药丸，非常方便。
It gives countries a fighting chance to push back on disease and to reclaim land that has been abandoned due to infestation. To date, five countries, have eliminated river blindness outright, and several more are really close. And all along, Merck has sold a drug under the brand name Heart Guard to prevent heartworms and hookworms in dogs. These products quickly became the top-selling veterinary medicines in the world, earning more than $1 billion annually. So yeah, Merck made their money, as they deserved to. And in 2015, Satoshi Amora and Merck's William Campbell were awarded the Nobel Prize in Medicine,
它让各国有机会反击疾病，并收回因寄生虫侵扰而被废弃的土地。迄今为止，已有五个国家彻底消除了河盲症，还有几个国家也已接近目标。与此同时，默克公司一直以“心虫清”（Heart Guard）的品牌名称销售一种药物，用于预防狗的心丝虫和钩虫。这些产品迅速成为世界上最畅销的兽药，每年收入超过10亿美元。所以，是的，默克赚到了他们应得的钱。2015年，大村智和默克的威廉·坎贝尔被授予诺贝尔医学奖，
for their discovery of Iver Meckton. Parasites are not generally regarded as being lovable. When we refer to people as parasites, we are not being complimentary. Here is Campbell accepting the honor. We tend to think that a parasite is the sort of person who goes through a revolving door on somebody else's push.
以表彰他们发现伊维菌素。寄生虫通常不被认为是可爱的。当我们称人为寄生虫时，这并不是在夸奖。这是坎贝尔在接受荣誉时的发言。“我们倾向于认为寄生虫是那种通过旋转门时靠别人推的人。”
This is unfair. It's unfair to real parasites, to the innumerable and influential parasites from the world of nature. Your majesty's, your royal highnesses, your excellencies, ladies and gentlemen, it is time for parasites to get a little more respect. We could end our story here. A miracle drug, a Nobel Prize, millions of lives. improved, billions of dollars earned, somehow everyone is a winner. What a story. But that is not where this drug story ends. Because here, our story takes a turn. Growing concern about a new and
“这不公平。这对真正的寄生虫，对自然界中无数且具有影响力的寄生虫来说是不公平的。陛下、殿下、阁下、女士们、先生们，是时候让寄生虫得到更多的尊重了。”我们可以到此结束我们的故事。一种神奇的药物，一个诺贝尔奖，数百万人的生活得到改善，数十亿美元的收入，不知何故每个人都是赢家。多么好的故事。但这不是这个药物故事的终点。因为在这里，我们的故事发生了转折。对一种新的、
rare pneumonia-like virus that has caused at least two deaths and has spread from China to other countries in Asia. The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention has confirmed the first U.S. case has been detected in Washington State. This is truly an unprecedented situation. This virus doesn't discriminate. It attacks everyone. I want every American to be prepared. In late 2019, a new disease emerged, COVID. And suddenly, Ivermectin was front page news.
罕见的类似肺炎的病毒的担忧日益增加，该病毒已造成至少两人死亡，并已从中国传播到亚洲其他国家。美国疾病控制与预防中心已确认华盛顿州发现了首例美国病例。这确实是一个前所未有的情况。这种病毒不分彼此。它攻击所有人。我希望每一位美国人都做好准备。2019年底，一种新疾病出现了，新冠肺炎。突然间，伊维菌素成了头条新闻。
I have today declared that the coronavirus presents a public health emergency in the United States. Public health emergency. A declaration of emergency. State of emergency. COVID-19 can be characterized as a pandemic. We will be suspending. all travel from Europe. I am officially declaring a national emergency.
“我今天宣布，冠状病毒在美国构成公共卫生紧急状态。”公共卫生紧急状态。宣布紧急状态。国家紧急状态。新冠肺炎可以被定性为大流行病。我们将暂停所有来自欧洲的旅行。我正式宣布国家紧急状态。
It was quite crowded, and we had to wait outside for about 20 minutes before they let us in. Jumping to March 16th. This is part three side effects. Now, usually side effects are unwanted or undesired consequences of a drug. But sometimes those unintended consequences actually open the door to new uses for the drug. It's called repurposing. Repurposing for medicines is oftentimes a medicine may be developed for one reason, one indication, and it may have off-target effects for a different disease process.
当时非常拥挤，我们不得不在外面等了大约20分钟才被允许进去。时间跳到3月16日。这是第三部分：副作用。通常，副作用是药物产生的不受欢迎或非预期的后果。但有时这些非预期的后果实际上为药物的新用途打开了大门。这被称为“药物重定位”（repurposing）。对于药物来说，重定位通常是指一种药物可能是出于某种原因、某种适应症而开发的，但它可能对不同的疾病过程产生脱靶效应。
So Viagra, everyone knows about Viagra. So Viagra was initially developed as a blood pressure medicine. This is Dr. David Bulware, a professor of medicine and infectious disease physician at the University of Minnesota. It didn't really work that great as blood pressure medicine, but it had some off-target side effects. So those side effects, people were like, oh, this is a thing. So it was then repurposed for sort of erectile dysfunction, even though it was originally developed as a blood pressure medicine. That's a famous example of something that's repurposed. Now remember when COVID hit the U.S. in 2020, nobody knew anything.
比如伟哥，每个人都知道伟哥。伟哥最初是作为一种降压药开发的。这是大卫·布尔沃（David Bulware）医生，明尼苏达大学的医学教授和传染病医生。“它作为降压药效果并不好，但它有一些脱靶的副作用。所以那些副作用，人们就觉得，哦，这是个东西。于是它就被重定位用于治疗勃起功能障碍，尽管它最初是作为降压药开发的。这是一个著名的药物重定位的例子。”现在记住，当新冠肺炎在2020年袭击美国时，没人知道任何信息。
There was no obvious treatment. So there were a lot of ideas, some absurd ideas about what would work. Some people said bleach would kill the virus, or methylene chloride. That's also known as paint stripper. Ultraviolet light was supposed to work. In India, one politician held a cow urine drinking party, and 200 people showed up. There were so many teas and solves and extracts.
没有明显的治疗方法。所以有很多想法，一些关于什么有效的方法甚至很荒谬。有些人说漂白剂可以杀死病毒，或者二氯甲烷。那也被称为脱漆剂。紫外线被认为有效。在印度，一位政客举办了喝牛尿派对，有200人参加。有太多的茶、药膏和提取物了。
And then there were supplements. People were crushing the store, trying to get their hands on various supplements. This is Simone. She worked in a grocery store in Portland, Oregon, in the supplements, section. She had a front row seat to the frenzy. Vitamin C, vitamin D, zinc, elderberry, and NAC. Oh, Quercetin also.
然后是补充剂。人们在商店里疯狂抢购，试图买到各种补充剂。这是西蒙（Simone）。她在俄勒冈州波特兰的一家杂货店的补充剂部门工作。她亲眼目睹了这场狂热。维生素C、维生素D、锌、接骨木莓和NAC。哦，还有槲皮素。
Right. And these all, like, help the immune system in theory. Yes. And the energy was very chaotic. Yeah. It was just a really weird time. And then there was the idea to repurpose drugs. Chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine and a xythromycin. That's an antibiotic. It kills bacteria, not viruses like COVID. And then, on April 4th, 2020, Ivermectin entered the conversation. The drug was first mentioned in a paper published in the journal Antiviral Research.
没错。这些在理论上都有助于免疫系统。是的。当时的气氛非常混乱。是的。那真是一个非常奇怪的时期。然后就有了药物重定位的想法。氯喹、羟氯喹和阿奇霉素。那是一种抗生素。它杀死细菌，而不是像新冠病毒那样的病毒。然后，在2020年4月4日，伊维菌素进入了讨论范围。该药物首次在《抗病毒研究》（Antiviral Research）杂志发表的一篇论文中被提及。
Dr. Bulware explains what the study said. There was a publication that came out that talked about how Ivermectin had in a petri dish kind of lab situation where Ivermectin had an anti-viral effect against SARS-CoV-2. You put enough of anything in a petri dish and a high enough concentration, it will start inhibiting just cells and like kill the cells. And so when I saw that, I was like, ooh, I was kind of, you know, I was interested. And is that concentration achievable in the human body with normal dosings? And so when I did the mathematics kind of backed in the calculation, it was like a hundred times higher level than you would ever achieve in the human body. And within about five minutes, realized like this is unlikely to be a viable treatment option because the concentration needed for an antiviral effect is so high. So because it would kill the virus, but it would not be good for the human either.
布尔沃医生解释了这项研究的内容。“有一篇发表的论文谈到伊维菌素在培养皿这种实验室环境下对SARS-CoV-2具有抗病毒作用。你在培养皿中放入足够浓度的任何东西，它都会开始抑制细胞，甚至杀死细胞。所以我看到那个时，我就想，哦，我当时有点感兴趣。那种浓度在人体内通过正常剂量能达到吗？当我进行数学计算时，发现它比你在人体内能达到的水平高出一百倍。大约五分钟内，我就意识到这不太可能成为一种可行的治疗方案，因为抗病毒作用所需的浓度太高了。”所以因为它会杀死病毒，但对人体也不好。
I mean, it's just so far beyond the normal dosing range that you would, to get that dose, you'd have to take a massive amount and you'd run in a toxicity. likely because a lot of things work in a petri dish, a lot of things work in a mouse, like, my gosh, we can cure cancer in a mouse, we can cure heart disease in a mouse. But it doesn't mean that whatever drug is always going to work in humans, but it's a starting point that you start there and then you've got to do a clinical trial to actually test it and see is there actually a benefit in actual humans with the disease. Now, Dr. Bulware and others spotted this right away, that it would take a huge dose, a dangerously huge dose in humans, to have the same effect. That was a pretty significant limitation, basically a disqualifier. But it was lost in the heat
“我的意思是，它远远超出了正常的剂量范围，为了达到那个剂量，你必须服用大量的药物，你会导致中毒。很可能因为很多东西在培养皿里有效，很多东西在老鼠身上有效，天哪，我们可以在老鼠身上治愈癌症，我们可以在老鼠身上治愈心脏病。但这并不意味着任何药物在人类身上总是有效，但这是一个起点，你从那里开始，然后你必须进行临床试验来实际测试它，看看在实际患病的真实人类身上是否真的有益处。”现在，布尔沃医生和其他人立刻发现了这一点，即在人体内需要巨大的剂量，一种危险的巨大剂量，才能产生同样的效果。这是一个相当显著的局限性，基本上是一个排除因素。但它在当时的热度中被淹没了。
of the moment. And the media was all over this study. One headline said, Ivermectin kills COVID in 48 hours. Newsweek wrote, anti-parasite drug used since 1980s may help stop coronavirus, news study says. Okay, that was not what the study said. But so it goes. Just days later, another paper appeared, proposing even stronger evidence for Ivermectin. This paper claimed it had data from a company called Surgesphere, based in Chicago. Supposedly, they had records from nearly 1,400 COVID patients from hospitals around the world. Half of these patients, the paper claimed, had been treated with Ivermectin in the first days of the pandemic. remarkably, the ivermectin patients showed a much lower mortality rate than patients who had not taken ivermectin.
媒体对这项研究大肆报道。一个标题写道：“伊维菌素在48小时内杀死新冠病毒”。《新闻周刊》写道：“新研究称，自1980年代以来使用的抗寄生虫药物可能有助于阻止冠状病毒”。好吧，那并不是研究的内容。但事情就是这样。仅仅几天后，另一篇论文出现了，提出了伊维菌素更强有力的证据。这篇论文声称它拥有来自芝加哥一家名为“Surgesphere”公司的数据。据称，他们拥有来自世界各地医院近1400名新冠患者的记录。论文声称，这些患者中有一半在大流行初期接受了伊维菌素治疗。值得注意的是，伊维菌素组患者的死亡率远低于未服用伊维菌素的患者。
Just over 1% of the ivermectin patients died compared to more than 8% of the non-Ivermectin patients. This was a staggering result. But the data was sloppy and inconsistent. And when other researchers asked to see it, the surgesphere researcher demurred. and he eventually disappeared. It was all fake. All made up. The doctor behind Surgesphere, Sophan Desai, he was discredited.
伊维菌素组患者的死亡率仅略高于1%，而未服用伊维菌素的患者死亡率超过8%。这是一个惊人的结果。但数据草率且前后矛盾。当其他研究人员要求查看数据时，Surgesphere的研究人员拒绝了。他最终消失了。这一切都是假的。全是编造的。Surgesphere背后的医生索凡·德赛（Sophan Desai）名誉扫地。
He holds the dubious honor of being among the first hustlers to try to exploit COVID for fame and fortune. The only trouble was that the headlines were already out there. These two papers and others published with fake Surgesphere data they have been cited by other researchers thousands of times. The damage was done. Here's a Senate hearing from December 2020 into quote-unquote hidden treatments for COVID,
他拥有一个可疑的荣誉，即成为第一批试图利用新冠疫情谋取名利的人之一。唯一的问题是头条新闻已经传开了。这两篇论文以及其他发表的带有虚假Surgesphere数据的论文已被其他研究人员引用了数千次。损害已经造成。这是2020年12月的一次参议院听证会，讨论所谓的“新冠隐性疗法”，
convened by the Honorable Ron Johnson of Wisconsin. We are now in December. This is three to four months later. Mountains of data have emerged from many centers and countries around the world showing the miraculous effectiveness of ivermectin. It basically obliterates transmission of this virus. If you take it, you will not get sick. The speaker was a Wisconsin doctor named Pierre Corey. In August 23, the American Board of Internal Medicine revoked Dr. Corey's board certifications for spreading false or inaccurate medical
由威斯康星州的罗恩·约翰逊（Ron Johnson）议员召集。“我们现在是12月。这是三四个月后。来自世界各地许多中心和国家的大量数据表明，伊维菌素具有奇迹般的有效性。它基本上消除了这种病毒的传播。如果你服用它，你就不会生病。”发言的是一位名叫皮埃尔·科里（Pierre Corey）的威斯康星州医生。2023年8月，美国内科委员会撤销了科里医生的委员会认证，理由是他传播虚假或不准确的医疗信息。
information. So what did those mountains of data actually say? Well, turns out Dr. Bulware was among those doing the hard work away from the TV cameras. And I got involved with something called Active Six, which was a public-private partnership. I was sponsored by NIH and was run out of Duke. It's a co-chair. So we looked at Ivermectin. We looked at guillotene. We looked at inhaled steroids that are used for asthma. We did sort of the normal dose of Ivermectin, three days of viromectin early in treatment to see, could you reduce the rate of hospitalization and could you get better faster? There are three trials I was involved with, over 1,000 people per trial and basically no statistical benefit over placebo. And no, like, you can't be like, oh, you just need
信息。那么这些堆积如山的数据到底说明了什么？事实证明，Bulware博士是那些在电视摄像机之外默默进行艰苦工作的人之一。我参与了一个名为“Active Six”的项目，这是一个公私合作伙伴关系。我由美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）赞助，并在杜克大学运行。我是联合主席。我们研究了伊维菌素，研究了羟氯喹，还研究了用于哮喘的吸入性类固醇。我们对伊维菌素进行了常规剂量的测试，在治疗早期使用三天的伊维菌素，看看能否降低住院率，能否让人好得更快。我参与了三项试验，每项试验超过1000人，基本上没有显示出比安慰剂更好的统计学益处。不，你不能说，哦，你只是需要
more people because there was no benefit whatsoever. And so for me, like, after the first trial, I was like, okay, I'm pretty convinced. And then the second trial is like, well, I'm pretty convinced. But then they said, oh, no, higher dose. So we use a higher dose. So we use a higher dose. And it's like, okay, third trial, higher dose, longer duration, and there was no benefit whatsoever. And so to me, I was, I mean, I thought that kind of closed the door on it. And that was in 2022. But still, like, people are still talking about it, still promoting it. And it's bizarre to me.
更多的人，因为根本没有任何益处。所以对我来说，在第一次试验后，我就想，好吧，我相当确信了。然后第二次试验，我想，好吧，我相当确信了。但后来他们说，哦，不，剂量更高。所以我们用了更高的剂量。所以我们用了更高的剂量。然后就像是，好吧，第三次试验，更高的剂量，更长的疗程，结果仍然没有任何益处。所以对我来说，我的意思是，我认为这已经为它关上了大门。那是在2022年。但即便如此，人们仍然在谈论它，仍然在推广它。这对我来说很奇怪。
Because it's one thing up front when we didn't know and there was some prelim data that suggests, no, maybe this is beneficial. But, like, we've got multiple trials, like, you kind of need to move on to something out. Usually for most physicians, like, I don't really have any vested interest in drug X or drug Y, just want to know which one works better. And so, yeah, most people have just kind of moved on, but some people were really kind of enamored with it and kind of stuck with things that didn't make any sense scientifically long after the data suggested they should have moved on to something else. So no effect on the RCT placebo-based trials. But they did see something interesting when they did not use a placebo. what's called an open label study,
因为起初我们不知道，而且有一些初步数据表明，不，也许这有益处，这是一回事。但是，我们已经有了多项试验，你真的需要转向其他东西了。通常对于大多数医生来说，我并没有对药物X或药物Y有任何既得利益，只是想知道哪种效果更好。所以，是的，大多数人已经转向了，但有些人确实对它非常着迷，并且在数据表明他们应该转向其他东西很久之后，仍然坚持那些在科学上毫无意义的事情。所以随机对照安慰剂试验中没有效果。但当他们不使用安慰剂时，他们确实看到了一些有趣的事情。这就是所谓的开放标签研究，
where you can actually see what you're taking. When you did an open label, what's from an open label study where if they got an inhaler versus they got nothing, there was a benefit. And so kind of psychologically, this also speaks to why if you give any medicine, particularly in COVID where the vast majority of people
你可以清楚地看到你正在服用什么。当你进行开放标签研究时，如果他们得到了吸入器而其他人什么都没得到，就会有益处。因此，从心理学上讲，这也解释了为什么如果你给予任何药物，特别是在新冠疫情中，绝大多数人
are going to get better, people think they got better because they got the medicine. And so on the individual patient perspective, like even if you give them medicine and doesn't have any benefit, they're going to feel better faster than if you give them nothing, which is kind of an instrument. It's the placebo.
都会好转，人们会认为他们好转是因为他们服用了药物。因此，从个体患者的角度来看，即使你给他们服用没有任何益处的药物，他们也会比什么都不给感觉好得更快，这是一种工具。这就是安慰剂效应。
Right. Yeah. So it is a real effect. It's just not the medicine. It's just not the medicine. But it's like, yeah, and it's like the power of thinking, but it's, yeah, the placebo effect. So it's a real thing. This is an important finding because in the real world, this is how people were taking
对。是的。所以这是一种真实的效果。只是不是药物的作用。只是不是药物的作用。但这就像，是的，这就像思维的力量，但它是，是的，安慰剂效应。所以这是一个真实存在的东西。这是一个重要的发现，因为在现实世界中，这就是人们服用
medicines, all sorts of medicines, including ivermectin, and open label. They saw the label, they took a dose, and a lot of them felt better. Here is Simone again. This is the woman who managed supplements at the Portland grocery store. She went to a natural path with her husband before she got COVID. I knew that I wanted to have ivermectin on hand, but it wasn't super easy to get a hold of. And he was able to get a prescription at a compounding pharmacy. Can you walk me through kind of what happened when you first got COVID?
药物的方式，各种各样的药物，包括伊维菌素，在开放标签下。他们看到了标签，服用了剂量，很多人感觉好多了。这是Simone再次出现。这位女士曾在波特兰的一家杂货店管理补品。她在感染新冠之前和丈夫一起去看过自然疗法医生。我知道我想手头有伊维菌素，但并不容易买到。他设法在一家配药药房拿到了处方。你能跟我讲讲你刚感染新冠时发生了什么吗？
My husband had just had knee replacement surgery, and the next day is when I came down with COVID. And so I was very out of it for the first 24 hours. I literally just slept by day three of the incredible body pain that I was experiencing. and within a couple hours of taking just the one pill, I just felt amazingly improved. Probably, I don't know, 80% of the body pain had gone away. It was just pretty mind-blowing, actually. I mean, I would take it again.
我丈夫刚做了膝关节置换手术，第二天我就感染了新冠。所以前24小时我非常迷糊。我基本上只是睡觉，到了第三天，我经历了难以置信的身体疼痛。在服用那一片药后的几个小时内，我感觉好多了。可能，我不知道，80%的身体疼痛消失了。这实际上非常令人震惊。我的意思是，我会再服用它的。
Now, I want to say, I appreciate Simone's perspective and her willingness to share her story. She did not have to, so I am grateful to her. And I think her experience shows how hard this is to figure out. She had COVID, she took Ivermectin, and she got better. She believes Ivermectin worked for her, and she has reason to. As Dr. Bulwer explained, sometimes it just works that way. But there is a difference between experience and evidence,
现在，我想说，我很欣赏Simone的观点以及她分享自己故事的意愿。她本不必这样做，所以我很感激她。我认为她的经历表明弄清楚这一点有多难。她得了新冠，服用了伊维菌素，然后好转了。她相信伊维菌素对她有效，她有理由这么认为。正如Bulware博士所解释的那样，有时事情就是这样。但经验和证据之间是有区别的，
and during a global crisis, it can be really difficult to let the science play out. to me, COVID was just a heartbreaking time, not just because of the million people in the U.S. who died of the virus, or the 7 million who died worldwide. What breaks my heart six years later is how COVID broke the trust between government and the citizens government should serve, between science and the people science is trying to help,
在全球危机期间，让科学发挥作用可能真的很难。对我来说，新冠是一个令人心碎的时期，不仅因为美国有100万人死于这种病毒，或者全世界有700万人死亡。六年后的今天，让我心碎的是新冠如何破坏了政府与政府应服务的公民之间的信任，破坏了科学与科学试图帮助的人民之间的信任，
between public health and the public. COVID was certainly not the only factor at work. But man, did it do a doozy on the trust people put in each other and in our institutions? It made it difficult for all of us to know who can we count on. Who can we put our faith in? In February 2021, Merck, that's the company that discovered Ivermectin, they put out a statement saying that their scientists had reviewed all available research. And they found that they identified, quote, no meaningful evidence for clinical activity or clinical efficacy in patients with COVID-19 disease. And this was Merck. They stood to make a lot of money if Ivermectin did work.
破坏了公共卫生与公众之间的信任。新冠当然不是唯一的影响因素。但是天哪，它对人们彼此之间以及对我们机构的信任造成了巨大的破坏。这让我们所有人都很难知道我们可以依靠谁。我们可以信任谁？2021年2月，默克公司，也就是发现伊维菌素的公司，发表声明称他们的科学家审查了所有现有研究。他们发现，引用，“没有有意义的证据表明其在新冠肺炎患者中具有临床活性或临床疗效”。这就是默克公司。如果伊维菌素真的有效，他们本可以赚很多钱。
And then in September 2021, there was a statement from the American Medical Association and the American Pharmacist Association. Quote, strongly opposing the ordering, prescribing, or dispensing of Ivermectin to prevent or treat COVID-19 outside. of a clinical trial, unquote. Not only did they say it wasn't helpful, but that ivermectin was demonstrated to be harmful to patients. But for those who had already lost faith in the medical establishment,
然后在2021年9月，美国医学会和美国药剂师协会发表了一份声明。引用，“强烈反对在临床试验之外订购、开具或配发伊维菌素以预防或治疗新冠肺炎”，引用结束。他们不仅说它没有帮助，而且还证明伊维菌素对患者有害。但对于那些已经对医疗机构失去信心的人来说，
this was probably just more fuel added to the fire of distrust. They wanted their medical freedom to do their own research and make their own choices. Now, I'm not going to chronicle everything that happened with COVID. I'm not getting to vaccines or lockdowns where the virus originated, that story is not this story. I will just note that in late 2021,
这可能只是给不信任的火焰又添了一把柴。他们想要他们的医疗自由，去进行他们自己的研究并做出他们自己的选择。现在，我不会记录新冠发生的所有事情。我不会谈论疫苗或封锁，也不会谈论病毒起源，那个故事不是这个故事。我只想指出，在2021年底，
YouTube decided to remove videos from their platform that contained dangerous coronavirus information. Over one million videos were removed. But there are still many videos there, thousands of them, and more still on TikTok or Instagram. And sometimes it just takes one video to get people talking again. I'll tell you a good story. Okay.
YouTube决定从其平台上删除包含危险冠状病毒信息的视频。超过一百万个视频被删除。但那里仍然有很多视频，成千上万个，TikTok或Instagram上还有更多。有时只需要一个视频就能让人们再次谈论它。我给你讲个好故事。好的。
I have three friends. All three of them at stage four cancer. All three of them don't have cancer right now at all. And they had some serious stuff going on. What did they take? Jesus. They took some what you've heard they've taken. Ivermecting.
我有三个朋友。他们三个都患有四期癌症。他们三个现在根本没有癌症了。他们当时的情况很严重。他们吃了什么？天哪。他们吃了你听说过的他们吃的东西。伊维菌素。
Phenbendazole? Yeah. Yeah, I'm hearing that a lot. They drank hydrochloride something or other. There's studies on that now where people have proven that they've... People drinking methylene blue and stuff like... Yeah, methylene blue, which was a fabric dye. Yeah.
芬苯达唑？是的。是的，我经常听到这个。他们喝了盐酸什么什么的。现在有关于这个的研究，人们已经证明他们……人们喝亚甲蓝之类的……是的，亚甲蓝，那是一种织物染料。是的。
Yeah, it was a textile dye. And then they find out has profound effects on your mitochondria. Yep. Yeah. This stuff works, man. There's a lot of stuff that does work, which is very strange. Because, again, it's profit. That was, yes, Academy Award winner,
是的，那是一种纺织染料。然后他们发现它对你的线粒体有深远的影响。是的。是的，这东西管用，伙计。有很多东西确实管用，这非常奇怪。因为，再说一次，这是利润。那是，是的，奥斯卡奖得主，
Mel Gibson and comedian Joe Rogan back in January 2025. More than 12 million people have watched that episode. Now, there is no evidence for any of that, in fact. There have been many, many studies looking into the potential therapeutic effects of Ivermectin on various cancer, ovarian cancer, liver cancer, breast cancer, pancreatic cancer, lung cancer, and so on. Different cancers can have very different courses in the human body. So drugs that work in one type, often, very often, do not work in another kind of cancer. Most of the research so far is in vitro, in a petri dish. So the same caveats as above. What works in a petri dish or a mouse, it may not work in a human being. It may kill the cancer, but in amounts that could also kill the human. And none of these have been
梅尔·吉布森和喜剧演员乔·罗根在2025年1月。超过1200万人观看了那一集。现在，事实上，没有任何证据支持这些说法。已经有许多许多研究调查了伊维菌素对各种癌症的潜在治疗效果，卵巢癌、肝癌、乳腺癌、胰腺癌、肺癌等等。不同的癌症在人体内可能有非常不同的病程。因此，在一种癌症中有效的药物，通常，非常通常，在另一种癌症中并不有效。到目前为止，大多数研究都是体外研究，在培养皿中进行的。所以有和上面一样的警告。在培养皿或老鼠身上有效的东西，在人类身上可能无效。它可能会杀死癌细胞，但剂量也可能杀死人类。而且这些都没有进行
large-scale randomized control trials in humans. So the data is scant, despite what Mel Gibson says. But what has changed is who was in charge back in Washington. And in February 2026, the new director of the National Institutes of Health, who has said the NIH should serve as the research arm of Maha. Hey, everyone, I'm here today to tell you how we can make America healthy again. And the head of the National Cancer Institute said that they had funded studies of Vyvermectin cancer treatments that are already underway.
大规模的人类随机对照试验。所以数据很少，尽管梅尔·吉布森这么说。但改变的是华盛顿掌权的人。2026年2月，美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）的新任院长表示，NIH应该作为“让美国再次健康”（MAHA）的研究部门。嘿，大家好，我今天来这里是为了告诉大家我们如何能让美国再次健康。国家癌症研究所的负责人表示，他们已经资助了已经在进行的伊维菌素癌症治疗研究。
Here's what the head of the NIH said. If lots of people believe it and it's moving public health, we at NIH have an obligation again to treat it seriously. Well, that's not actually the way it's supposed to work. Just because people believe something does not mean it's worthy of study or that it is worth the money, our money, to do the research. But whatever, that's the way they make decisions now. Studies are underway.
这是NIH负责人所说的。如果很多人相信它，并且它正在推动公共卫生，那么我们NIH就有义务再次认真对待它。嗯，这实际上不是它应该运作的方式。仅仅因为人们相信某件事，并不意味着它值得研究，或者值得花钱，我们的钱，去做这项研究。但无论如何，这就是他们现在做决定的方式。研究正在进行中。
Maybe it works. Who knows? And the great state of Florida isn't far behind. In late 2025, the Surgeon General of the Sunshine State announced a $60 million cancer innovation fund that would study, among other things, the value of Ivermectin for cancer treatments. This is fine. It's what I have argued for in this show, after all. Do the science. Test your hypotheses. But like Dr. Bulwer explained, if it does not work, move on. Find something better. Because even when you test something that doesn't work, you still get a lot of placebo effects. And each of those becomes an anecdote, a story, a testimonial. And to a lot of people, anecdotes are much more compelling than statistics and P values and relative risk reduction calculations.
也许它有效。谁知道呢？伟大的佛罗里达州也不甘落后。2025年底，阳光州的卫生局局长宣布了一项6000万美元的癌症创新基金，该基金将研究伊维菌素在癌症治疗中的价值等。这很好。毕竟，这也是我在这个节目中一直主张的。做科学研究。测试你的假设。但正如Bulware博士所解释的那样，如果它不起作用，就继续前进。寻找更好的东西。因为即使当你测试无效的东西时，你仍然会得到很多安慰剂效应。而每一个效应都变成了一个轶事、一个故事、一个推荐。对很多人来说，轶事比统计数据、P值和相对风险降低计算更有说服力。
And we should expect a lot more anecdotes. Recently, five states, Tennessee, Arkansas, Idaho, Louisiana, and Texas have voted to make ivermectin available over-the-counter without a doctor's prescription. These states are not seen an upsurge in hookworm or any river blindness. It's just for people who want it on hand just in case. In the name of, yes, medical, Freedom. But freedom's just another word for trying to sell you something. Just look at supplements. It's no coincidence that a lot of people promising unproven things have a product they want you to buy.
我们应该期待更多的轶事。最近，田纳西州、阿肯色州、爱达荷州、路易斯安那州和德克萨斯州这五个州投票决定让伊维菌素可以非处方购买，无需医生处方。这些州并没有出现钩虫病或河盲症的激增。这只是为了让那些想要的人以防万一。以，是的，医疗自由的名义。但自由只是试图向你推销东西的另一个词。看看补品就知道了。很多承诺未经证实的东西的人都有他们想让你买的产品，这绝非巧合。
This idea of evidence, of validity, it matters because when doctors or scientists say something doesn't work, they are not trying to deny people access to something. They're not trying to hide something. In fact, they're trying to find something, something that works. And they're generally trying to save people from wasting time and money and hope. And hope is particularly precious here because disease makes people desperate. And nothing is more valuable in desperate times than hope. That's it for this episode of Drug Story. For an annotated list of our sources for this episode,
这种关于证据、有效性的想法很重要，因为当医生或科学家说某件事不起作用时，他们并不是试图剥夺人们获得某种东西的途径。他们不是试图隐瞒什么。事实上，他们是在试图寻找某种东西，某种有效的东西。他们通常是在试图挽救人们免于浪费时间和金钱以及希望。而希望在这里尤为珍贵，因为疾病使人绝望。在绝望的时刻，没有什么比希望更有价值。这就是本期《药物故事》的全部内容。如需本期节目的注释来源列表，
visit drugstory.com. Drugstory was created, written, and hosted by me, Thomas Gets. Rachel Swaby is our producer and sound designer. Mark Bush is our engineer. Molly Warner is our research director. Drug Story was produced with support from the University of California, Berkeley School of Public Health. Thank you to our guests, Simone, and Dr. David Bulwere.
请访问drugstory.com。《药物故事》由我，Thomas Gets创作、撰写并主持。Rachel Swaby是我们的制片人和声音设计师。Mark Bush是我们的工程师。Molly Warner是我们的研究总监。《药物故事》是在加州大学伯克利分校公共卫生学院的支持下制作的。感谢我们的嘉宾Simone和David Bulwere博士。
Drug Story is an independent production. If you would like to support, To support our work, contact us at drugstory.com. You can also subscribe to our substack there and be notified when new episodes come out. And I want to let you know we are gearing up for a season two. We have a lot more drug stories to tell. This episode of Drug Story might cause itching, scratching,
《药物故事》是一个独立制作。如果您想支持，支持我们的工作，请通过drugstory.com联系我们。您也可以在那里订阅我们的Substack，并在新剧集发布时收到通知。我想告诉大家，我们正在为第二季做准备。我们还有更多的药物故事要讲。这一集《药物故事》可能会引起瘙痒、抓挠，
and Googling of terms like delusional parasitosis. We recommend you wear shoes, wash your hands, and grant your doctors and yourself... A little more respect. You can listen to all of the first season of Drug Story at Drugstory.co. Go listen. It is fantastic. Season two is currently in production. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及对“妄想性寄生虫病”等术语的谷歌搜索。我们建议您穿上鞋子，洗手，并给予您的医生和您自己……多一点尊重。您可以在Drugstory.co收听《药物故事》第一季的所有内容。去听听吧。它非常棒。第二季目前正在制作中。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。